you
everyone is Jerry this is video five
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and we're going to have a look
at what to do when a chess opening there
are three stages to a chess game three
phases the opening middle game endgame
our focus in this video will be on the
opening so what should we do during it
what we should do is build a combative
structure and develop efficiently now
what do I mean by this what do I mean
exactly when I say build a combative
structure I have a couple things in mind
when I say this and they both point to
they both refer to the pawns and how
they interact with one another more
specifically I'm talking about creating
and or challenging a pawn duo we'll see
exactly what I mean by a pawn duo soon
enough and also we're looking to make a
pawn break if needed
the term pawn break is when we covered
already in video four to be exact
we'll see how that ties into the opening
and when I say develop efficiently I'm
talking about getting our pieces out to
active squares having them placed on
squares where they have many options
we're looking to get castled when I say
develop efficiently we're looking to get
castled so our king is safe and also we
don't want to waste any time we don't
want to move the same piece multiple
times in the early stage of the game but
rather get all of our pieces out and
have them contribute there's a big
reason I chose the word efficient I
wanted to draw your attention to not
only getting the pieces to active
squares but also not wasting any time
okay now we're going to see several
examples of this in action you're going
to see several examples of what I mean
by building a combative structure and
developing efficiently so that we can
have a better feel for
how the opening should be playing out
okay before I get into the specifics
before I get into the examples let me
first start with a definition what
exactly am i referring to when I say
Pandu oh well this right here is a pawn
duo a pawn duo is when you have two
pawns on the same rank right next to
each other this is what we might call a
D and E pawn duo this is also known as
an ideal pawn center
it's another term we could be using but
from here on out I'll be referring to it
as a pawn duo it's the most common pawn
duo in chess having both of your central
pawns up on your fourth rank if we're to
look at it from blacks perspective just
making some passing moves some dummy
moves on the white side this would be
the ideal on center or the pawn duo for
black to both central pawns up to the
fourth rank here let's go back here to
the white side what is it about this
pawn duo that is so good there's let's
let's look at what it is doing drawing a
lot of tension I realized the pawns they
are worth the least in the game but that
is no indication of how important they
are they are most important they we
might regard them as the blueprint in
chess they are going to provide
instructions to our other pieces they'll
help our other pieces know where they
belong they will be particularly
particularly useful to our bishops our
bishops will be our pawns how they are
positioned will influence where our
bishops belong and making pawn breaks
will influence the major pieces the
rooks and the queens they will be
helpful to creating
open files or half open files let's have
a look at what this pond duo is
currently doing from here just clearing
the board there
what squares are being controlled let's
see right off the bat here they're
controlling four squares that's nice but
it's not just that this is four squares
in the enemy position and that could be
quite inconvenient we can be sure that
pieces of greater value will not be
making use of those squares these pawns
can take them out but that's not just
that's not the only thing that makes a
pond duo so strong it's not just the
squares they control but also what they
could do what prospects they have the
flexibility they have for example
suppose one moves forward notice that it
has now support by the other pond that's
nice to have coordination and chess to
be moving your pieces about and have
them protected we have this exact case
right here and this pawn here what we
might regard as a head pawn is now
controlling two new squares two new
squares that are now deeper in the enemy
position and that could be quite
annoying to the enemy side taking away
those squares and similarly we can move
forward with this pawn we have the
support and we're controlling two
squares deeper into the enemy position
so it's very nice to have a pawn duo not
only because of the squares they control
but also because of the flexibility they
have maybe one day he most moves forward
maybe one day he moves forward or maybe
you don't move at all maybe you keep
your opponent guessing as to which pawn
advance you'll make or maybe you won't
make any pawn advances I'll just leave
them simply sitting they are a big deal
in chess this pawn duo so much so that
every nearly every chess opening will
address a pawn duo will combat a pawn
duo challenge a pawn duo okay we're
going to see this in action soon enough
let me just point out that beyond that
this pawn duo the one with the D and E
pon the next that is the most common
pond duo
that ideal pond duo the D and E pond the
next most common is this one right here
these are the two most frequent pond
duo's you will see in chess a C and D
pawn duo and also this D and E pawn duo
okay those are the the two pond duo's
I'm going to focus on the most if we
have a look at this pond duo right here
this is not as common and one reason for
this just a very quick reason is because
this F pond will often like to stay home
because what's most likely to happen in
the game what's most common when it
comes time to make when it comes time to
get our king castled he likes to Castle
kingside
that's easily done there's only two
pieces that need to be cleared out
compared to castling queenside where you
would need to move three pieces so when
we Castle kingside we would really like
to have these three pawns stay home so
it's not as weakening to have your pawns
close to your king is a nice home for
your king it's the best arrangement to
have your pawns close to your king
moving this pawn up here having this
type of a pawn duo contributing or
having your C pawn contribute to forming
a pawn duo a C and D pawn structure this
is quite common and not going to be
weakening once you castle on the Kings
side so let's have a look at some
examples here of this in action let's
see what I mean again when I say build a
combative structure and develop
efficiently the first example the first
example actually is a terrible example
from Black's perspective I just wanted
to show you an example here where black
is ignorant to something black is being
ignorant right now to whites forming of
a Pandu
black is going about development of
their minor pieces usually a very good
idea to go towards the center but what
good is a piece developed towards the
center if it cannot be maintained there
and what we're soon going to see here is
that black is going to get kicked around
this night's being attacked he has to go
elsewhere if he goes here well now he
will be dead soon enough he's trapped he
has to go home the other nights getting
kicked around and white is getting
developed and before you know it this
night here is going to be cooked he's
going to be dead now I realize this is a
very exaggerated example I showed here
but my main point of emphasis was to
show that if you don't do something
about a pond duo things could seriously
go wrong for you in a big big way okay
we're going to see much more better
examples better examples where we combat
a structure so let's let's start with
this one right here suppose the game
starts off with e4 what like is what
light can do next is simply form a pawn
duo now how can we interfere with this
how can we combat this idea how can we
look to challenge this pawn duo
well this example that I'm showing right
now is a direct way to deal with one
side forming a pawn duo what do I mean
by this well let's see in response to e4
response to this move we can follow up
with E 5 and this is a direct way to
deal with the forming of a pawn duo
because as soon as this pawn is on board
black could simply snap that pond right
off take it right out we get a couple
developing moves in we're moving towards
the center we're getting our minor
pieces out after this d4 move light has
a pawn duo but black is able to take it
right out after this recapture black let
me just pause right here for a moment
what has black done they have combated
they've challenged White's pawn duo ok
they've broken that
up and from here we're looking to get
all of our pieces out develop
efficiently not move it we're not
wasting any time and I'm just going to
go in each of these examples I'm just
going to go ten moves in just to give
you a feel for how the pieces can be
coming out both sides are castled
neither side has moved the same piece
more than once in the opening if play
was to continue a rook playing here
would be nice a bishop coming out here
maybe the Queen stepping up the rook
coming over on this half open file
getting all of our pieces out in
contributing is the name of the game now
let's look at another example here one
where it is yet again a direct way to
meet a pawn duo after efore what's
another direct way to deal with one side
threatening to form a pawn duo well we
could play c5 as soon as this move is
played and white as a pawn duo black is
there to take it right out but first
let's get a couple more developing moves
in and now we have d4 black is in a
perfect position to do what break it up
combat that pawn duo pawn takes Knight
takes and we're going to now look to
develop efficiently notice if black is
not taking right here and doing
something else
well this Knight he's usually really
well placed if he's towards the center
like this but he's going to have to find
a new home that pawn will kick him away
a black breaks up that pawn duo and what
do we do from here we get our pieces out
we're not looking to waste any time
we're not moving multiple pieces in the
early stage of the game there'll be
exceptions to every rule of course but
generally speaking we're looking to get
all of our pieces out efficiently
without wasting any time again just
going ten moves in if play was to
continue this would be a nice move this
one would be a nice move as a follow up
for the white side getting to half open
files or open files for our rooks let's
have a look at covered some direct ways
to deal with the pawn duo let's have a
look at some indirect ways also be
provide
fighting in this video well actually
what we could already observe from these
two examples and we'll see in at each
ensuing example from now on is that we
never obstruct our central ponds we
don't put ponds I'm sure just go back to
that other example here this one here
after we have this c5 move you'll notice
we're not obstructing our center ponds
we're not moving pieces in front of our
center ponds we want to allow them
freedom of movement we want to be able
to maybe one day create a pond do oh we
can't do that if we're blocking them in
so a good rule of thumb is to simply not
block your central ponds okay
additionally there are some other things
I would like to share with you for
example in this this game right here
suppose suppose after d4 d5 I actually I
misspoke when I said this was a indirect
way of dealing with the pond oh uh this
is another direct way to deal with a
pond do well if your opponent starts
with the d4 you could hit that pond
head-on and play d5 so now if your
opponent tries to form a pond duel like
this you can take it out in this example
that's going with c4 forming a pond duel
black is in a perfect position to simply
break it up and capture however in this
example does something different playing
e6 being in a position to meet pawn
takes pawn with upon recapturing and now
being in a position to once again
prevent white from forming a pond ooh oh
okay over in this example we don't have
this capture right here instead we're
looking to now get some development and
we're looking to develop efficiently
black has been successful with building
a combative structure we're looking to
get our pieces out our minor pieces out
and getting castled we have this C pond
playing a role here now this is a very
interesting moment there's something
that I would like to emphasize
that I think is going to be quite useful
when it when it comes time for you to
play the opening stage of the game and
it runs as follows here's a good general
principle to follow and that is if you
or our excuse me if you and/or your
opponent has their deep on on their
fourth rank which is the case right here
both sides in fact have their D pawns on
the fourth rank if you and/or your
opponent has their deep on on their
fourth rank the C pond will very often
like to advance okay we're seeing this
in action right now and I'm I'm
referring to that phrase right now and I
don't want you to simply memorize it I'm
going to provide reasons for why that is
a good idea okay there are there are
plenty of reasons I will be just
scratching the surface with the few that
I share with you one reason to do this
is well for one you may be wanting to
form a pandu of your own this last move
this fourth move by black is doing just
that they're forming a pawn duo
additionally you'll notice this move is
striking at the opponent's deep on
striking at the opponent's pawn duo you
could also I I said that the deep the
sea pawn will like to advance if you or
your opponent has they're deep on on
their fourth rank the C pawn will very
often like to advance sometimes you may
not want to strike at your opponent's
center but you would like to maybe
reinforce your own Center okay the main
point here is to simply not obstruct
your C pawn he will very often like to
contribute in the game in fact these
three pawns these guys here the starting
point of the game the C D and E pawns
are the pawns that move the most in a
chess game the they are most frequently
moved in this game is playing to c5 won
a dish
reason for this is that it opens up a
diagonal for the Queen
notice when that c-pawn is up the Queen
has some new prospects coming out in
this direction three possibilities for
the Queen and three possibilities for
the three possibilities for each sides
Queen okay
so just keep that in mind if you and/or
your opponent has they're deep on on
their fourth rank the C pond will very
often like to advance so don't be so
quick to block it in with four examples
doing something like this moving your
knight to the C six square yeah it's a
developing move but it's kind of awkward
now to clear out your pieces okay it's
kind of stuck maybe you want you to get
your Queen out here first important to
get that C pond working so we'll see
that in ensuing examples and this is
getting the C pod working but just
following through with this this example
we're getting our pieces out we're
getting castled we're not wasting any
time
just going ten moves in here and if play
was to continue rooks getting to these
half-open files and this bishop coming
out this Queen may be coming out like so
hopefully you're getting the idea here
let's have a look at a few now this is
this is I mean at this time when I say
let's have a look at some indirect ways
that we can be combating a pawn
structure so have a look at this one
right here starting out with E for our
opponent can play c6 this is an indirect
way to approach a pawn duo ponent builds
this pawn duo what are we going to do we
can't break it up right away but we can
confront it we can challenge it by
playing pawn to d5 we're doing something
about this this pawn duo no longer has
the flexibility it would have if it was
not challenged white isn't able to go
here or here when there's a deep on
right here challenging it okay it's not
as flexible anymore
this particular example we're going to
have the capture and now following up
we're going to be developing efficiently
notice
we have one or more D puns
what was the phrase exactly if you
and/or your opponent has their D pawn on
their fourth rank as is the case right
here the C pawn will very often like to
advance or see an example right now
where the C pawn is advancing and
reinforcing this d4 pawn moving forward
we getting our pieces out and we're
getting castled we're not wasting any
time again just going ten moves in this
is as far as I want to take it half open
file half open file as ensuing moves and
let's have a look at a few more examples
here just three more examples as a close
here this one now starting out with d4
this is another example of an indirect
way of dealing with a pawn duo
we could have as soon as it's formed its
confronted head on like this with d5
we're getting some development in here
and I'd like to also draw your attention
to something that just happened right
there these last few moves that just
took place here this is an important
detail I referenced that we don't want
to block our central pawns with our
pieces another thing I want you to keep
in mind is the relationship between our
pawns and our bishops I want you to
focus on move order a little bit
thinking maybe just two moves ahead and
this will draw our attention to timing
just a little bit
notice this move here by white Bishop to
g5 black makes a casting a move we have
a couple pawn captures and then we make
the move III we know in the game we want
to get both of our bishops out at some
point but in what order should they be
played should we try to get this guy out
here and then move this bishop well
notice if we do that if we play this
move first he's kind of stuck this right
here is regarded as a pawn chain just a
couple terms here black has this small
little
pawn chain here and this is this is
White's little pawn chain if we can we
would really like to get this Bishop
outside of the pawn chain where he is
not obstructed where he's not blocked in
by his own pawns we can't always do this
but if we can do it we would like to get
him out and about before we block him in
so there's a little bit of coordination
to be thinking about in other words so
that's why this bishop comes out and
only then do we have this move III so
keep this in mind the relationship
between pawn structure and your bishops
okay so just moving forward getting a
few more pieces involved only going ten
moves in we're really not wasting any
time and as a follow-up move we could
maybe go with something like this and
just getting the Queen out maybe here at
some point maybe playing something like
a5 that's getting into a little bit of a
plan but this is as far as I want to
take it minor pieces out getting castled
we're not wasting any time let's look at
just two more examples one where we
begin with efore another indirect way to
deal with a pawn duo is to start with e
six and after the pandu is formed you're
confronting it with d5 okay
it loses its flexibility not as many
options now black has combated the pawn
structure combated the pandu oh we have
a couple captures in the name of the
game here is getting our pieces out two
active squares and getting our Kings
castled once again a case where we have
one or more D pawns on the fourth rank
one or if you enter your opponent has
they're deep on their fourth rank the C
pawn will very often like to advance
we're having these guys advance
they're both reinforcing the D pawns and
we're getting our rooks to have open
files or open files and let's have a
look at just one more example here one
where we don't have the opening up of
files so we
we need to work a little bit sometimes
in order to allow our rooks to play okay
so in this example we're once again
seeing this pawn duo being confronted
but instead of this capture now we're
going to have this advance and all the
examples up to this point that I've
shown I was going in for variation or
some move sequences where I made a pawn
capture but suppose there aren't pawn
captures made what are we doing such a
situation here because one day we want
to get our rooks working but we need
pawn breaks that earlier point I made
when I said to not only create and/or
challenge a pawn duo but to also make a
pawn break if needed well in this
position it's needed if we're not making
a pawn break our rooks will not be
playing an active role so we need to
look to make a pawn break and black and
do that right now on move three with
playing c5 striking at the D pawn or
once again seeing a case where we have
the D pawns on the fourth rank one or
more d puns on the fourth rank here
C pawn will very often like to move it's
moving yet again and another reason this
might be good idea is because what it's
forming a pawn duo okay so this is going
to be helpful to our rooks of course
it's going to have a capture at some
stage a rook can be well placed then on
the C file and we'll be able to get all
our pieces out and about we'll be able
to develop efficiently play might
continue as follows in fact we're seeing
yet another way to make a pawn break
striking here we're making a pawn
advance that will result in a pawn
capture in the opening up of a file
getting some more developing moves in
we're getting castled getting all of our
pieces out again I'm just going ten
moves in here and this is as far as I
want to take it if play was to continue
Brooke here Knight here rook here you
get the idea hopefully these are some
good examples just again going ten moves
in minor pieces out just a very quick
summary here taking it from the top what
do we look to do here in each of these
examples we look to build
combative structure and develop
efficiently to create and/or challenge a
pond duo to make a pond break if needed
developing efficiently I'm talking about
moving again pieces to active squares
getting castled not wasting time don't
block your central ponds recognize the
relationship between your bishops and
your ponds trying to get your bishop
outside of your pond chain
coordinate your bishops in other words
with your pawns if you and or your
opponent has they're deep on on their
fourth rank the C pond will very often
like to advance and some reasons for why
that is the case you may be wanting to
advance your C pond again to form a pond
duel of your own a C and D pawn duo you
may want to strike at your opponent's
deep pond you may want to simply protect
your own deep pond and you're also by
moving your C pond you're giving your
queen some breathing space you're
allowing your queen to come out along a
diagonal and I'm sure there are more
reasons but I think that's enough that's
more than enough to get us going here in
the opening stage of the game okay so
that's all for this video
we'll see what happens in video 6 and as
always I hope you got something out of
this video take care bye
you